[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: You've made it to
the last lab in the quest.
After you complete
this lab on Qwiklabs
you will finally
unlock your badge.
Are you familiar
with Qwiklab quests?
Quests are a series
of labs organized
by technologies, specific
services, or particular use
cases.
There's no need to
complete an entire quest
in a single sitting.
But by completing each
individual lab in a quest,
you can earn badges that reflect
your newly acquired skills.
On this episode,
we're going to go over
what you'll learn in this final
lab in the GCP Essentials quest
and set up network and
HTTP load balancers.
In this hands-on on
lab, you'll learn
the differences
between a network load
balancer and an
HTTP load balancer
and how to set them up for
your applications running
on Google Compute
Engine virtual machines.
This lab will take
you through the steps
to set up two types
of load balancers
in Google Cloud Platform--
L3 network load balancer,
L7 HTTPS load balancer.
You will create an instance
template with a specified
startup script,
create a target pool
to allow us a
single access point
to all instances in a group,
create a managed instance
group using the instance
template with two VMs,
view the created instances,
and configure a firewall
to connect to the
machines on port 80,
create a level 3 network load
balancer targeting the instance
group we created, list the
forwarding rules in our project
to see the target of our
group is our instance group,
and use the IP address
at the load balancer
to visit the load
balancer from a browser.
In the remainder of
the lab, you will also
create a HTTPS load balancer.
Is this it?
Is this the last
lab on your quest?
Congratulations-- we
want to hear from you.
Tell us about your experience
following this Qwiklabs quest
and how you're
applying what you've
learned in your own applications
in the comments below.
See you next month, when we'll
embark on our next quest--
baseline infrastructure.
[MUSIC PLAYING]